[Music]
Nicole Tiffany I know isn't it weird
yeah maybe like Hall Oh weird what not
Alexandra that's my middle lane Lambos
narrow great Oh nothin anymore I'm
calling to you because I know you're
gonna love this one
is it ever done related no but it is
something like another thing that you
okay okay is a cat related not yet
what's another thing Stan that's Eminem
what are you known for like the florist
oh oh here we go
you know it's Mercury retrograde but it
is real make any big decisions don't
worry how somebody commitments don't be
sad big contracts wasn't a good one a
retrograde for like six months no for
like six years
really what yeah I've been signing
really big contracts lately n uh July
17th but how long it's been going off
for you've been saying it's been a
retrograde from that what if there was
another retrograde in the beginning it
was like in February or something will
happen that the July 17th
well you got to wait a week for the
shadow period and then you can sign some
contracts how convenient that taxes are
due right before Oh Shh you couldn't you
cannot defer taxes right this year
because of coronavirus do you don't get
a fee on the extension because of
coronavirus so you actually could file
first I think the new deadline is July
15 I don't care is this month no for
sure
Annie what the taxes already files well
okay this French restaurants coordinate
its menu with lunar cycles oh [ __ ] yeah
battery sounds tight though so it's got
like a little cancer plan right so if
it's full moon you get a full filet
mignon and if it's not the need a sliver
is it a crab right now
because it's cancer Oh love you okay so
this chef his name is Mao rucola Gor
reco and he is a chef at a very popular
restaurant in Paris buddy
hmm and so he was saying this is quote
during the lockdown I worked a lot in
the garden it allowed me to work out all
my worries and to be really in contact
with the earth so when it came time for
him to reopen his restaurants he decided
to base his menus on the lunar cycle
like he had been at home oh he's has his
own garden so he says that he began to
question a lot of things like the way
that they work the way society is
developing and the way that we produce
and consume and so they wanted to shake
that equation and to say that the garden
was part of the restaurant and the
restaurant was part of the garden so a
lot of what they do is biodynamic so for
example when they sow spinach they do it
on a leaf date which is when the moon is
rising because there will be bigger
concentration of energy on that part of
the plant and so for on days that the
moon is in any of the air signs they are
called flower days and on those days
they would serve something like shrimps
with rose petals rhubarb and almond milk
and so he's saying that this is a like
heat he sees this as a way to help bring
his customers more into direct contact
with nature that's pretty cool I like
that that's like Mickey winter clothes
today
nice really yeah Oh Fung Shui is like
that too of the elements no it's a
per-person based on when you're yeah
it's based on birthday today what's the
reasoning but like was it like all of
this stuff like because like farming
anyway so it's kind of like going back
full circle because like back in the day
they kind of like have harvest
surely because he's using like astrology
like and he's doing a monthly cycle and
sounds like a big seasonal cycle Oh like
summer solstice sure like bad you know
yeah harvest winter time that makes
sense though right it's like there's
better energy to the plant so like on
the day that there's strong energy good
plant you're like serving the planet
might taste better [ __ ] yeah even beyond
just like the plant itself physically or
scientifically but like even in
intention and energy which you know I
believe in that right you better it's
like the intention to even do that it's
so important right it's like it's not
about like oh I have to wear this on
this day or whatever it's then it makes
you think about certain things on
certain days like like if I don't wear
blue blue today I'm not gonna die this
is crazy gonna have I mean I might die
but it's not because of that it's more
about like so blue represents positive
change so throughout the damn just
focusing on positive change I'm more
like more aware of positive change we're
positive change is happening and it's
almost like a self-fulfilling prophecy
we're like what you focus on gross so if
you're focusing on positive change it
doesn't matter that the blue led you to
that it's just that like it's a nice
reminder and like you're kind of serving
that intention that's really cool and
that's kind of cool you remember all
that too because I like I like to like
read about things and I'm like oh that's
really interesting but I don't actually
like dive myself into it like astrology
and stuff I'm just like oh that's what
people say about my sign doesn't sound
like me but okay and then I kind of move
on but I'm able to like read it but not
necessarily yeah be about it but like I
don't base my whole life I'm not like
religious about it a lot of people think
that it's like if you like any of that
you're into like hocus-pocus you're very
close to wartime it's just fun to read
about and in like this is fun take what
you want and leave the rest you know I
am Aries that's such an Aries thing to
do
that's such an Aries thing I never
really like cared as much and it's not
that I'm aware anything like that but
like every single time you don't want
people who are really hyper focus on
that any time you do something like
you're so jamming on your Gemini right
one
so Gemini yeah that's annoying yeah well
it happened for so long that fine was
like you know what [ __ ] it I am a Gemini
that allows me to do all these weird
things that you think I'm gonna do
anyway my intention is to be Gemini yeah
I chose this that's more fun that way
but did you know that like when they
develop this stuff the month is actually
one-off yeah there's an extra 13 well
you're supposed to be the next Noah
source me if you're born after 2009 why
because of the agent query yes it's when
everything shifted
what should the what he's talking about
yeah like so people born in May now
aren't born under the Taurus stars
they're born under the Pisces stars or
whatever it was when they developed this
and they were doing astrology like they
were basing it off of the that what they
saw but there's been a shift so now
because there's a shift that it's not
the same timeframe like the month of
Aries is not April it's so is it like
overnight or like it's like every year
like you know how we set back the clocks
and forth okay so which I think only we
knew by the way no it's not daylight
savings I don't know but I'm just saying
like things like that we're gradually
over time like Oh correct it's not
exactly 365 days to the years so there's
gonna be like that's why there's leap
year a day that were it's like it gets a
little bit shivers in it also because
during that time frame and correct me if
I'm wrong but there's also just like
every like twelve thousand years or
something which is why like we shift
those ages and whatnot but like there's
polar magnetic shifts as well which is
what makes the shift in this yeah
so once the work changes set then that's
why you don't see the same thing anymore
because TrueNorth it shifts like this so
the earth it doesn't stay still it's
like teetering like this so like for
example like the Mayans or I think it
was the Aztecs or whatever they
calculated the correct North during
their time but it's off alignment now
because basically the earth had its
polar shift well like it's like a yeah
it's like a tilt right so then they
seemed like they were off by a few
degrees
but they're actually right which is
probably I believe also why they
calculated that the whole myth that in
2012 was the end of the world it was
because it was the end of the Mayan
calendar right in terms of like how
things were meant to be accurate to that
understanding but just like we probably
don't need more than 2012 it's like a
long time from now
or just like the math is perfect until
then after that you guys figure it out
carrying right now hopefully the aliens
come down to help you with your map at a
time come back yeah
or they ran out of ayahuasca and they
couldn't think anymore
I need more toads to lick I wonder at
what point like how much that was real
and then the art was lost throughout
history what art like what if it was
like like horoscopes and all those like
what do you call it astrology because
there's Chinese astrology too and
there's a lot of more like that in
ancient religions but then throughout
time you corrupt it with money and all
this stuff and then it's like the
spirituality and all that stuff
disappears and it becomes a business
right we have totally lost our way yeah
we're not in tune with the nature the
same way anymore because even there's a
lot of Buddhism that's like that like
where it's like it used to be connected
or whatever and then now you just go
there and it's like a gold Palace and
you just forget you pay for like
forgiveness and that's like most
religions pay for your wishes so
function y similarly where it's it's
based on the like orientation of your
door to your house and stuff and so like
One Direction is fire and then this is
water and over here's wood and here's
metal and you put different objects
represent those things and they also
hold meaning like the fire is your
respect corner like Fame respect
prestige all of that and it's associated
with red and anything like fiery and the
shape is triangle so like all things
that are like candles or you know star
shapes or lights or that goes in that
area then there's destructive elements
like water puts out fire so if you put
water elements in the fire your ruin
your prestige or your ruining your
respect area so then what happens at
that point I like fire like cancels it
yeah like so if you're a neutral ground
well if you look at your life and you're
like oh like my career is not doing so
hot like what's going on over here and
yeah did you look at like careers
represented by water and like the
destructive element is earth so maybe
you have a lot of like yellow in that
area or you have a lot of Earth's stuff
in that area so and it's not about like
the actual thing people get really
wrapped up in like oh if I put this dumb
logic here then it means that they know
if you have that attitude then it
doesn't matter what you put there it's
more about the intentions like you were
talking about like the intent to fix
this area up and then you're just like
naturally you're thinking about your
career more but it's to get the energy
flowing in a certain way in your house
the attitude in general to care enough
means that you have an attitude that
cares yeah what about the special powers
that's what I care about
I want to meditate so [ __ ] hard that
aliens talk to me and I have a special
message that nobody [ __ ] you can see
for that that's also real [ __ ] though
right like people that like use
meditation right to like enter higher
frequencies to do things like physical
healing even that's what I'm trying to
do that's the real thing that's the wim
HOF breathing the heal everything you do
without breathing yeah yeah by I'm not
disciplined right now I just did video
three studies what's that the wind hop
breathe said this guy's super famous for
like being able to like climb like Mount
Everest with his like shirt off and
stuff because he's been able to use
breathing techniques to use his mental
power to control his like you know
entire body ohm dude you know I was just
talking I think about that recently
where I want you to go climb no no no it
was more like mind over matter thing
where I forgot what the context of the
conversation was but it led to me saying
something along the lines of like you
know I'm able to like find peace and
pain so like when I'm in physical pain
oh it's because we had just gotten back
from the orthodontist so we both
same orthodontist so he like got
tightened and stuff and then I got a new
trays so like everything was like
pulsating oh yeah and so he was just
like he was in a lot of pain and I was
like I said honestly me too and we're
like trying driving home
well now I'm like I'm like you know what
I tend to do that I end up finding peace
in pain is where like I'm focusing on
how like the sensations of what it feels
like so I could feel like the tingling
moving from my jaw going all the way up
to the top of my skull and like I feel
it like pulsating but it's like a warm
pulse and it's like slightly sharp and
like I'm describing what it feels like
and the more I describe it the more I'm
able to like cope with it and like it's
okay like it doesn't it's almost
embracing it a little bit yeah it's like
embracing it it doesn't tear me apart
where I'm like oh my god my head like
[ __ ] you know like that just makes it
worse so I was kind of like trying to
tell him like I think it's a sense of
like mindfulness that you're able to
deal with physical pain that's how
exercise is yeah it's like when you're
running you're like oh my god this
[ __ ] hurts my body but then you feel
like you just focus on breathing you're
like oh actually okay I can feel free I
can feel free in in this but if you're
like oh good then you can't breathe and
then you don't relax and if when you
start looking at the time like you're
like I'm gonna run for 20 minutes you're
like okay you're running oh that's God
I've been five minutes yeah I'm go super
slow you're I try to go by this songs I
like if each songs about four minutes
then if I go on this song I'll go faster
on this song I'll sprint for the first
part of it until the chorus or whatever
[Music]